Democrats kick off a major twenty20 Town
Hall by endorsing voting rights for
terrorists and rapists we examine the
novel electoral strategy then AO sees
star fades Isis claims responsibility
for that terrorist attack in Sri Lanka
and we examine why leftists weep for
puppies
but not for babies I'm Michael Knowles
and this is the Michael Noel's show
[Music]
a gift from the gods last night or the
opposite of the gods the 2020 Democratic
candidates for president you know that
all of the cable networks have been
doing these town halls for the various
candidates Fox did it Fox had one for
Bernie Sanders
obviously CNN and MSNBC so CNN had a big
one that that happened with most of
these major candidates out there how do
you think these candidates are going to
differentiate themselves we've got 20
candidates in the race obviously some
more serious than others some sitting
senators some sitting governors some
local mayors some people you've never
heard of how are they going to stand out
and make sure that their voices are
heard above the din of everybody else
why they're going to endorse voting
rights for terrorists and rapists of
course Bernie Sanders kicks it off and
sets the tone for the night senator
Sanders you have said that you believe
that people with felony records should
be allowed to vote while in prison does
this mean that you would support
enfranchising people like the Boston
Marathon bomber a convicted terrorist
and murderer do you think that those
convicted of sexual assault should have
the opportunity to vote for politicians
who could have a direct impact on
women's rights if somebody commits a
serious crime
sexual assault murder they're going to
be punished they may be in jail for 10
years 20 years 50 years their whole
lives that's what happens when you
commit a serious crime but I think the
right to vote is inherent to our
democracy yes even for terrible people
so I believe that people commit crimes
they pay the price when they got out of
jail I believe they certainly should
have the right to vote but I do believe
that even if they are in jail they're
paying their price the Society but that
should not take away their inherent
American right to participate in our
democracy at least he's an honest
radical you did this to yourselves
Democrats you did this to yourselves by
reacting so strongly and by moving so
far to the left that this man is
currently one of the frontrunners
for your party voting rights not just
for felons who have gotten out of jail
but for terrorists for rapists and not
just once they've gotten out of jail but
while they are still in jail to put this
in perspective because I think we're
just so used to radicalism now and
extremism we say oh yeah of course
Bernie Sanders is endorsing voting
rights for terrorists even Chris Cuomo
whose brother is the Democrat governor
of New York Andrew Cuomo whose father is
one of the most famous Democrats in
history Mario Cuomo even Chris Cuomo
basically begs Bernie Sanders please
Bernie don't take the Democrat Party
down this road my follow-up question
goes to this being like you're writing
an opposition ad against you by saying
you think the Boston Marathon bomber
should vote not after he pays his debt
to society but while he's in jail you
sure about that well Chris I think I
have written many xxxii opposition ads
throughout my life this will be just
another one but I do believe look you
know this is what I believe do you
believe in democracy do you believe that
every single American 18 years of age or
older was an American citizen has the
right to vote no Chris maybe you didn't
hear me I think that not just felons but
the Boston Marathon bomber and rapists
should vote now Bernie Sanders here says
I've written many opposition ads against
me that line didn't get the reaction
that I think he thought it was gonna get
I think Bernie Sanders thought that line
was gonna sound like I'm really tough I
say things that are unpopular and
therefore I'm really courageous what
that sounds like is I say a lot of
stupid things because that's what that
means the reason you get opposition ads
against you is because you say stupid
things or you say something that out of
context
sounds bad even though in context it's
really not bad but obviously it's not
the latter case here because Bernie
Sanders has asked to excuse me Bernie
let's put this in context or are you
sure you want the Boston Marathon bomber
to vote he says yes of course what do
you got cotton in your ears there Chris
of course I want them to vote so you
can't say is being taken out of
context the reason that he's got
opposition as being made against him
here is because he's saying something
very stupid by the way that was from an
opposition at the group RNC Research
Republicans research opposition firm is
coming out and just posting clips no
nothing else no music no text just
allowing these candidates to say exactly
what they're saying and then we can all
use them we can all see them in their
entirety the other mistake that Bernie
Sanders is making here is that he is
making a mistake that not just Democrats
make Republicans do as well which is
creating an idol out of the franchise
creating an idol out of the right to
vote in the United States and our
representative democracy in our
democratic republic in our
self-government we have the right to
vote to give us good government we have
the right to vote to protect our
liberties we have the right to vote to
construct a country in which we can all
flourish and in which our country can
flourish the right to vote is simply an
instrument to give us all of those
things what the left here thinks is the
opposite they think that our whole
government just exists to give us the
right to vote does anyone really believe
we would have a great country
if well every terrorists could vote if
every rapist could vote if every
disgusting degenerate criminal monster
who hates our country and doesn't
believe in a thing that it stands for
had the right to vote how on earth would
that give us a good country how on earth
would that protect our liberties how on
earth would that create a nation in
which we can all flourish it wouldn't
and so we have certain restrictions on
the right to vote until very recently if
you were a felon you couldn't vote most
places now that's starting to change
because of Democrat politicians because
as always they're getting the country
exactly backwards there I like the right
to vote I'm perfectly happy with the
right to vote however let's say that
everybody I'm 29 years old let's say
that everybody who was 29 years old for
some reason
generational psychosis decided to vote
for communist candidates for some reason
all the 29 year olds were voting for
communists and it threatened our whole
country and we could elect communists
all around the country I would gladly
surrender my right to vote I would
gladly say okay 29 year-olds can't vote
anymore because it'll destroy our
country because that will certainly not
protect our liberties that certainly
won't protect human flourishing that
certainly won't protect the American
traditions and the American ideals I
don't really care it's not like I get
some great thrill from voting I do it
because it's my civic responsibility and
because I think that I certainly know
what's better for the country then all
these wacko left wingers like Bernie
Sanders so I go and exercise my vote as
a responsibility but it's not just some
great pleasure the country doesn't exist
to give me that right to vote Bernie
exactly
flips it but a judge was then asked
about this and Chris Cuomo he's he's
obviously looking for an out he's from
what would be considered I guess more of
the mainstream of the Democrat Party his
brother is an elected prominent national
Democrat governor of New York and so he
just wants to pull the Democrats back
from the edge please mayor Pete you're a
normal guy you're a level-headed guy
please tell me you don't think
terrorists should vote take it away
mayor Pete senator Sanders earlier this
evening said he's in favor of felons
being able to vote even while serving
their prison terms he was asked
specifically about people like the
Boston Marathon bomber people convicted
of sexual assault rape and other things
pedophiles he said the right to vote is
inherent to our democracy yes even for
terrible people
senator Kamala Harris just said we
should have that conversation she didn't
really answer one way or another what do
you think should people convicted of
sexual assault of the Boston Marathon
bomber should they be able to vote while
incarcerated yeah no I don't think so
I
I do believe that when you are out when
you have served your sentence then part
of being restored to society is that
you're part of the political life of
this nation again and one of the things
that needs to be restored is your right
to vote as you know some states and
communities do it
some don't I think we'd be a better
country if everybody did it and frankly
I think the motivations for preventing
that kind of reinforcement in in some
cases have to do with one side of the
aisle noticing that they politically
benefit from from that oh did you catch
that at the end he had a pretty good
answer here he says look look Anderson
I'm a I'm a moderate guy I don't think
people who were currently incarcerated
should be able to vote but once they get
out they've paid their debt to society
all these good people and so they should
get their right to vote back notice he
doesn't use the phrase Boston Marathon
bomber or rapists that's probably not
going to play very well but he says you
know look they've paid their dues okay
great then he says that the debate over
this issue comes down to a political
party that thinks they can benefit from
it now what he thinks he's doing here
what he was intending to do is launch an
attack on Republicans he's trying to say
Republicans want a block felons from
voting because felons vote for Democrats
but you see the change here isn't taking
the vote away from felons the law that
we're starting with is that felons don't
have the right to vote they don't have
the right to vote for a number of
reasons and a long political history and
a long tradition the people who are
trying to change the law are Democrats
so the party who is trying to change the
law because they think they can benefit
from it is Democrats and the reason that
they think they can benefit from it is
because they know that felons are a part
of the Democrat base that's what he's
admitting there in that answer he had a
pretty good answer I mean it was kind of
mealy-mouthed
classic Democrat weak nonsense but it
sounded pretty good until that little
bit at the end where he admitted that
the the motivation to change this lawn
to reinforce felons is naked ly
political
it's just because Democrats think they
can harvest votes why can they harvest
votes because criminals are basically
their base the other note you have to
see about but a judge here is that
Buddha judge isn't wearing a jacket but
a judge is just wearing a shirt sleeves
and a tie have some self-respect have
some respect for the office you are
running for president put on a jacket
you wear a jacket when you go to dinner
at a nice restaurant you wear a jacket
when you go to church on Sunday wear a
jacket when you're running for president
but they can't because they've all got
to be the cool guys I'm not a regular
politician I'm a cool politician I'm not
a regular mom I'm a cool mom oh I know
all those regular moms think that felons
and terrorists and rapists shouldn't
vote but I'm a cool mom
that's okay kids felons and terrorists
and rapists can vote I don't care if you
have a beer or two that's fine I'm a
cool I don't even wear a jacket that's
basically what what the Democrats are
positioning themselves as so what
they're trying to do is say look all
these laws all of these traditions yeah
we can weaken those let's weaken all of
those then we will be freer we talked
about this theme last week
the theme of liberation the theme of
emancipation this is one of the dominant
themes of the West throughout all of
modernity and the Democrat Party and the
left here is really taking up that
mantle and turning it up to 11
literally in their clothing they're
liberating their selves from their
jackets I don't need all this formal
clothing I'll be freer and they're
liberating the country from laws and
political traditions we don't need
boundaries around the franchise we can
open that up for everybody including the
Boston Marathon terrorist all in all
however Pete but a judge basically
performed better than most people here
these weren't the only people who were
asked about the right to vote for
terrorists and rapists Kamala Harris who
I previously thought was one of the
tougher candidates in the race gets the
same question from Don Lemon totally
bungles the answer Sanders said that
that he is in favor of felons being able
to vote while serving in prison he was
asked specifically about people like the
Boston Marathon
Baumer also people were convicted of
sexual assault and he said this is a
quote the right to vote is inherent to
our democracy yes even for terrible
people do you agree with that senator I
agree that the right to vote is one of
the very important components of
citizenship and it is something that
people should should not be stripped of
needlessly which is why I have been long
an advocate of making sure that the
formerly incarcerated are not denied a
right to vote which is the case in so
many states in our country in some
states permanently deprived of the right
to vote and these are policies that go
back to Jim Crow these are policies that
go back to the heart of policies that
have been about disenfranchisement
policies that continued until today and
we need to take it seriously but people
who are in convicted in prison like the
Boston Marathon bomber on death row
people who are convicted of sexual
assault they should be able to vote I
think we should have that conversation
oh my gosh everything was wrong about
this answer from beginning to end it
went from bad to worse you've got to
give a little bit of credit here I hate
to give credit to Don Lemon and Chris
Cuomo and Anderson Cooper they actually
did push the question and they did push
the candidates to answer what should not
be a tough question what should be a
very easy question but I guess for these
radical candidates is a tough question
Kamala Harris from the very beginning
Don Lemon says do you think that the
Boston Marathon bomber should vote and
you can hear in her voice the wheels
turning you can see on her face the
wheels turning she averts her eyes she's
looking down just well I believe almost
in a robotic sort of cadence that the
right to vote is very important she's
trying to figure out her answer she
should have figured out her answer
before it should be an obvious answer
and and then in this country sometimes
felons are not allowed to vote and
that's bad they should be allowed to
vote then she goes off on that tangent
for a little while and then she tries to
avoid the question Don Lemon pushes her
he says are you saying Camilla Camilla
please what are you are you saying that
the Boston Marathon bomber should be
allowed to vote well and I
leave that that is a conversation that
we should have so even at the end it's
this totally non-committal acceptance of
the suggestion that terrorists and
rapists should vote even in prison even
while they're incarcerated except it's
even if she had just come out like
Bernie and said yeah I think Osama bin
Laden should vote I think he should run
for president if she had at least said
that she would get points for courage
a bizarre courage a reckless craziness
but at least she'd get points for
confidence for standing on an opinion
for believing in something for for
having principles she doesn't get credit
for that because she doesn't have any
principles I got to tell you I really
thought that Kamala Harris could be one
of the top candidates for the nomination
I'm really beginning to doubt that what
made me think she could is that she's
got the political calculation of a
Hillary Clinton the problem is she's
also got Hillary Clinton's staff and I
think it's probably messing her up if
she staffed up basically with all the
people of the old Hillary Clinton
campaign and she's just a little too
calculating by half she's just a little
too clever by half she even has
Hillary's awful laugh that ha ha ha ha
you know that bizarre look on her face
and that strained and forced laugh she
even has that nothing about this woman
seems genuine everything seems
calculated you know early in this race
right when she announced Willie Brown
made this former California politician
said that basically commonly slept her
way to the top that was the accusation
and I don't know who pushed for the
story or who planted the story but
obviously that story was designed to say
that this woman doesn't believe in
anything she'll say anything to get
elected
she has no principle she has no belief
and she keeps proving them true she just
doesn't seem ready for primetime she
didn't get elected to the Senate that
long ago she's pretty young but she just
doesn't seem like she's ready there to
get the nomination not just on this
answer but on other answers to she was
asked about a bill that she voted for
for her health insurance program and she
tried to lie about it when she couldn't
lie
she just tried to twist the truth and
blabber her way out of it listen to this
this bill that you co-sponsored
essentially phases up private insurance
for four years in four years I don't
think that's right that's what the study
show that it would phase out I'm
actually supporting the bill that you
that you co-sponsor yes
we're co-sponsor with Bernie Sanders
Medicare for all would effectively
eliminate private insurance it was it
would essentially phase out private
insurance companies as the main source
but there would still be supplemental
there still be access to supplemental
insurance for whatever it's not covered
but let's be clear about it Medicare for
all under the plan that I am supporting
will extend coverage so where is right
now it does not cover dental vision
hearing aids under the plan Medicare for
all it will cover those those needs will
be covered they will be an extension of
it including mental health services
including what we need to do better
around women having greater access to
reproductive health care what okay yeah
and also also hey look over there what's
that then she scrams and there's a
Kamala shaped hole in the wall again
some points go to Don Lemon here he did
point out that study is on Medicare for
all show that it would eliminate private
health insurance Kamala Harris said she
would eliminate private health insurance
she walked that back that's why she's
walking back this this answer here but
what she just said is a lie Medicare for
all which actually isn't Medicare at all
would eliminate private health insurance
Medicare meant Medicare the program
Medicare is a federal program for senior
citizens whereby the federal government
pays for health insurance but the
federal government is using private
health insurance companies and markets
Medicare for all which is the socialist
health care being pushed by Democrats is
not simply a government funded program
it is government-run health care the
difference between government-funded
health care and government-run health
care is the private market these private
companies you hear this all the time
from people like Bernie Sanders and
everybody else pushing Medicare for all
is they say they want to get rid of the
insurance companies they want to get rid
of the middle
they want it to be a single-payer system
between the people and the federal
government that eliminates private
health insurance by definition she
admitted that at first Kamala Harris
then she was called out on it now she's
lying and pretending that it's something
else again even this is just an example
of her weakness if you're going to
become a socialist if you're gonna run
as a socialist run as a socialist Bernie
Sanders has had tremendous success
running as a socialist the man sang this
land is your land this land is my land
shirtless drinking vodka in the Soviet
Union that guy ran is almost an
out-and-out communist and he's done
pretty well he nearly became the
Democrat nominee in 2016 and he's
leading the pack for all intents and
purposes right now but but qumola just
doesn't know she's a weathervane she
wants to know do people want me to be a
socialist okay today I'll be a socialist
and I'll eliminate private health
insurance do people want me to be a
capitalist okay today I will completely
lie about the thing that I voted for and
say that actually it won't do the things
that it'll do weak sauce also true on
guns Kamala Harris is trying to have her
cake and eat it too on guns and again
she's resorting to lies have been
sleeping over the last two years part of
what has happened under the current
administration is they took fugitives
off the list of prohibited people I put
them back on the list meaning that
fugitives from justice should not be
able to purchase a handgun or any kind
of weapon so that's what I do
with this for your first executive
action as president well it depends on
what else happens that was able to do
that that'd be after 100 days okay so
what she just said that fugitives are
allowed to buy guns that is not true
that is a lie that what she is implying
here what she's suggesting is that the
Trump administration is allowing half a
million fugitives now to buy guns what
she's referring to does have a grain of
truth in it it is true that in recent
years half a million fugitives were
removed from the National instant
criminal background
check system but that happened under
Barack Obama that didn't happen under
Donald Trump that was an Obama era
policy to remove half a million
fugitives from the national background
check system the instant background
check system it also remains the case
the fugitives are not allowed to buy
guns so that is just an a blatant lie
and this is one thing that worries me
about Kamala Harris at least with Bernie
Sanders he's he's relatively honest his
world view is absolutely perverse and
the things he wants are evil
but at least he's relatively honest this
woman is an out-and-out liar she's the
Hillary Clinton of the race now 2016 was
Hillary Clinton's race to lose she lost
him I guess 2020 might be Kamala Harris
his race to lose she's losing it already
she was doing very well early on because
she was keeping her mouth shut so you
had people sniping at Liz Warren and
Pete but a judge and Joe Biden and
they're all going back and forth against
one another Bernie Sanders she was
trying to stay out of the fray you can
only do that for so long at a certain
point you have to come out and say who
you are and what you want to do it's not
going well for her when that happens and
and to double down on the radicalism
because she's so schizophrenic in this
campaign I'm I'm a moderate I'm a
socialist I'm a moderate I'm a radical
she comes out and endorses one of the
least popular policies in the country
impeachment of the president I believe
that we need to get rid of this
president that's why I'm running for the
to become president in the United States
so that is part of the premise obviously
of my point but I think we have very
good reason to believe that there is an
investigation that has been conducted
which has produced evidence that tells
us that this president and his
administration engaged in obstruction of
justice I believe Congress should take
the steps towards the Pietschmann this
is a pure lie she is lying through her
teeth
there was a two-year investigation it
did not produce evidence sufficient to
prosecute Donald Trump for obstruction
of justice this is Bob Muller didn't
come to a conclusion on obstruction of
justice however ultimately the question
goes to the Attorney General and to the
Deputy Attorney General in this case rod
Rosenstein who had been overseeing the
investigation
both William Bar the AG and rod
Rosenstein came to the prosecutorial
judgment that there is not evidence to
prosecute there is not evidence of the
crime of obstruction Trump is exonerated
I spoke yesterday when I was filling in
on Ben's radio show to Alan Dershowitz
Alan Dershowitz said certainly he agrees
with bar and Rosenstein and actually
says that Bob Muller got the question of
obstruction dead wrong the framework
that he was using was way too broad
would not hold up is not in the
mainstream of legal thought there simply
is not evidence to impeach Donald Trump
for obstruction or collusion and to push
this ridiculous line is a lie now how
did Kamala Harris wants to push
impeachment because she thinks it'll
rally up her base and maybe get her the
Democrat nomination for president fair
enough that's a fine political strategy
all the other candidates are thinking
that as well
including Elizabeth Warren but at least
Elizabeth Warren is a little bit more
honest about her motivation for
impeachment and what she thinks that the
true grounds of impeachment would be
other Democrats have been saying it's
not worth the political cost it's not
worth the Civic cost or or it's it's
arguably just too soon what made you
decide to take this stuff today well I
read the report I was on an airplane
yesterday and started reading it read it
way into the night last night and I got
to the end and realized this is about a
point of principle the report is
absolutely clear that a foreign
government attacked our electoral system
to help Donald Trump he welcomed that
help and then when it was investigated
by our own federal authorities Donald
Trump took multiple steps to try to
obstruct justice you know this is one of
those moments when I get it that there
are people who think politically no it's
going to be too hard to do this this
isn't about politics this isn't even
specifically about Donald Trump himself
there
this isn't about politics this isn't
about Donald Trump himself it's about me
it's about me Elizabeth Warren who's
running for president and I'm not even
registering in the polls and I need to
catapult myself to the top so I'm gonna
back impeachment it's it's a better
principle but not a legal principle and
not a political principle I guess it's
just about me it's about a selfish
principle I give her some points for
some honesty there I think that is much
more credible than Kamala Harris trying
to pretend trying to lie through her
teeth and say that there's some legal
basis for impeachment here if this is
another way in which she's like Hillary
is she's totally able to lie she appears
to do it effortlessly the trouble is
she's not very good at it so she can do
it effortlessly she just does it she
just doesn't do it credibly so you look
at her and you say I know you're lying
to me you're not even good at it very
weak performance I think among people
who are paying attention to politics
Kamala Harris really fell very very far
in everyone's estimation of whether or
not she can become president
Liz Warren herself will make her pitch
to be President Bernie will double down
on radicalism and Pete but a judge and a
bee Klobuchar will come in as weaklings
then by the way will Joe Biden even run
for president we're getting conflicting
reports we'll get into that in a second
but first this afternoon at 3:00 p.m.
the Yaak campus tour brings me to Cal
State Los Angeles the home of La Raza
where I will be giving a speech on
illegal immigration in the wall the
speech is called this land is my land
it's my favorite line from a pretty
mediocre song it's a free event so if
you're in the area please come on down
to the University Student Union theater
at 51:54 State University Drive and
enjoy the show by the way if you bring
super soakers don't you dare get it on
my jacket I've already lost one jacket
to a super soaker I do not need to lose
a second one if you can't make it in
person you can watch the live stream on
the daily wire Facebook page and the
daily wire YouTube channel got a second
bite of Facebook in YouTube go to daily
wire com 10 bucks a month $100 for an
annual membership you get me you get the
Android Lyman show you get the men
Shapiro
show you get the Matt Walsh oh you get
to ask questions in the mailbag coming
up on Thursday you get to ask questions
backstage you get another kit what don't
you get you get the leftist ears tumblr
you're gonna need it if the
super-soakers come out tonight you are
going to need the tumblr to catch the
tears go to daily wire comm we'll be
right back
so Liz Warren shows up to the townhall
even though she's barely registering in
polls she this is kind of do-or-die for
her at this point and she decides she's
gonna play it a little bit safer she's
not going to be making the pitch that
you should vote for her cause she'll
enfranchise felons and terrorists and
rapists instead she goes back to the
tried and true Democrat strategy of
promising to give people a bunch of free
stuff I have two parts to the proposal
part one is that we say that we are
going to roll back student loan debt for
about 95 percent of students who have
debt that's part one and then part two
is we'll roll it back for the other 5%
free stuff for everybody haha that's
more or less her proposal I love the
language that the Democrats used - we're
going to roll back debt - translate for
you from Democrats speak what that means
is we are going to take your money you
the taxpayer and then give it to some
students who made poor financial
decisions and took out a lot of loans to
get a worthless degree a degree that sir
almost certainly didn't educate them and
a degree that is also not applicable to
getting a job which is why they can't
pay back the loans so that's why you who
didn't make any of those bad decisions
now have to pay off the loans for them
also known as rolling back the debt just
gonna just roll it back I'm gonna roll
back your bank account we're gonna roll
back all of history so that you can
rethink making good financial decisions
then we're gonna roll it all forward and
you're good financial decisions are
going to be held against you when you
pay for other people's bad financial
decisions think about what this means
this means that you let's say you didn't
go to college you didn't take out two
hundred thousand dollars in debt you got
a job you worked for an extra four years
maybe six years maybe eight years if
they got a PhD you worked for all of
that time you did what you had to do you
made smart decisions
and you were responsible you guy who
didn't go to college or now going to pay
for a guy who did go to college who
statistically speaking is supposed to
make more money in the long run than you
will I think this is what they really
mean by income inequality that this is
the biggest income inequality I've ever
heard of people who have lower long-term
income predictions are going to pay
money directly to people who have better
chances at higher income in the long run
Democrats pushing income inequality as
ever but this is what they do they say
we'll pay you for everything forget
about how much it's actually going to
call us to forget about how it's
actually gonna look we'll do everything
for free okay Bernie Sanders goes a step
further he proves that he's still an
ogee socialist defending comments he
made in the 1970s about the Soviet Union
defending communism you were asked
earlier on as a quick follow on this
what do you feel differently about now I
was reviewing what CNN's Kaye file had
come up taking a look at your evolution
in politics you used to argue that you
should have government control the means
of capitalism of our energy companies
founded I said in the 70s okay right no
but what you say in the stuff I got
Google that's right oh what I'm saying
is that you've changed well wait a
minute I first thought you know he gives
me criticizing meteor all the time and
he gets nervous about it right one of
many things that makes me nervous all
right
is I was a mayor of a city for eight
years that I nationalize any of the
industry in the city of Burlington
Vermont I don't think so
congressman for 16 years look I said
what I said that's your excuse
your excuse for saying you want to
nationalize industries just like Fidel
Castro did and Joseph Stalin did and all
of the communist thug tyrants of history
did your excuse for that first of all
you don't apologize and you don't say
you don't believe it anymore
your excuses when I was mayor of
Burlington I didn't nationalize any
industries apparently unaware that you
can't nationalize something when you're
the mayor of a small town he says look I
was a congressman for 50 years 60 years
right you you were you've been a
congressman for a very long time you've
just been very ineffective is he saying
that I didn't really want to nationalize
all those things I didn't really mean
what I've been saying for the last 50
years I don't think that's what he was
saying I think what he's saying is I've
been so inept in the actual functions of
government in my actual career in
politics I've been so completely
ineffective that I haven't been able to
do any of the things that I've been
promising to do for half a century
that's his excuse don't worry that I'm a
communist I'm also extremely ineffective
don't worry that I'm a communist I'm
incompetent an incompetent communist
that's his pitch Bernie Sanders still he
gets points because he says things so
confidently this is why I think in
parties at the top of the polls these
other candidates are not there were some
weaklings here Pete but a judge not
wearing a jacket slumped shouldered
looking like he's 12 years old
not with a whole lot of gravitas is
asked he he initially said that Mike
Pence is doesn't like him hates him
wants to erase him from the world as
anti-gay he's a bigot this is not true
of course Mike Pence has only ever been
complimentary and kind to Pete but a
judge Pete but a judge completely made
this up to try to make himself look like
a victim Pete but a judge was then
called out for this and then
but a judge apparently can dish it but
he can't take it you got me was kind of
a back-and-forth public back and forth
between vice-president pence and
yourself over the issue of
discrimination against LGBTQ people and
faith the current ambassador to Germany
Richard Grinnell who's also gay he
weighed in on this saying that you had
been quote pushing this hate hoax along
the lines of Jesse's smollett for a very
long time now several weeks how do you
respond to that I'm not a master
fisherman but I know bait when I see it
and I'm not gonna take it
make haste while the Sun shines
thirty days hath September April June
and November
and when short February is done all the
rest have 31 Anderson that's my answer
if wishes were horses beggars would ride
it that's enough that's enough Pete but
a judge we don't need to hear anymore he
punts on the question it's pathetic he
can sling a totally unfair attack and
then the gay ambassador to Germany
Grinnell ambassador Grinnell comes out
and says this is a fake unfair attack
and Pete but a judge should answer for
it and but it just says yeah pass I
think I'm gonna pass week he would have
done better giving a Kamala Harris
answer just weak stuff not as weak
though as Amy Klobuchar remember Amy
Klobuchar she's the one who gave a
speech about global warming while she
was covered up to her shoulders and snow
Amy Klobuchar who basically throws desk
furniture at her at her staffers who's
throwing the office lamp at her aides
Amy Klobuchar who eats salads with combs
on airplanes and then hands them to her
staffer and says clean it so anyway I
was kind of hoping because Amy Klobuchar
is a tough lady that she could come out
and be the tough one in this race turns
out Amy Klobuchar is the Jeb Bush of
2020 I am someone that runs in a purple
state it is a state that when I first
started running for office the other
senator was Republican the governor was
Republican and three of our four
constitutional officers were Republican
and then I started running and every
single time I have run I have won every
single congressional district in my
state including Michelle Bachmann's
okay that's when you guys are supposed
to cheer okay all right please clap
please clip my name is jeb Klobuchar
please clap weak stuff don't ask for
applause if you're if you're gonna ask
for applause you got it really you've
got to really be playing with the
audience you've got to really have a
good rapport with the audience Amy
Klobuchar doesn't have a good rapport
with anybody she comes off as mean aloof
she does come off as a bit tough but
here she's trying to play retail
politics and it's just not working so I
think probably she's the weakest one in
this race right now after this Town Hall
Bernie radical as ever he what Bernie
promises us is he's gonna remain at the
top of the field for at least a little
while longer because he did have a
pretty good performance because he's at
the top of the field because he's one of
the better candidates in the race and
because he is the most radical candidate
in the race what that tells us is the
2020 primary race is going to remain far
left and radical for the foreseeable
future biggest loser of the night was
Kamala Harris she went from a top-tier
candidate and really hurt herself if she
can't figure out how to speak if she
can't figure out how to stop lying or at
least lie better she is going to fall
way down in the pack but a judge is okay
the bloom is off his rose a little bit
he played all right
but but wearing the shirt sleeves and
refusing to answer questions like he got
caught not doing his homework in the
eighth grade is not going to play well
for a guy who looks like he's 12 years
old he has to show people that he's an
adult he has to show people that he can
go from running a very small town in
Indiana to running the whole country and
he's not going to be able to do that if
he continues to pretend to be Howdy
Doody or somebody or Leave It to Beaver
ain't gonna work and Amy Klobuchar
really had to make a move here she
didn't she didn't move the needle
Elizabeth Warren maybe helped herself
just a little tiny bit because she gave
direct answers and went to a tried and
true Democrat strategy speaking of
weakness though somebody was missing in
that Town Hall you'll notice who was
missing creepy Uncle Joe himself Joe
Biden was supposed to announce his
presidential run on Wednesday Frank Lee
was supposed to Anne
a while ago and he's been kind of
playing doing this hamlet game it was
supposed to be on Wednesday he was
supposed to go drop the video on
Wednesday then do stops in
Charlottesville Pittsburgh and
Philadelphia this has been known for
weeks at this point and then all of a
sudden it's not happening apparently now
we're getting some reports that he might
announce on Thursday
now we're getting some reports he might
not announce it all why is that well I
can show you in a 30-second video listen
to this the basis of the behavior that I
talked about was something much more
serious than just a hug I mean that's
where the conversation devolved into but
that's not where it started we talked
about the fact that I had no previous
relationship with the vice president
that it was moments before a
high-profile event where I was supposed
to speak to hundreds of people it was
unexpected he was behind me he held on
to my shoulders he got close to my body
from behind smelled my hair kissed my
head all all moments before I was
supposed to do this event and that isn't
hot a hug that is just unprofessional
inappropriate behavior no matter who
does it but certainly from at the time
the second most powerful man in the
country I guess the real question for
2020 Democrats is once Joe Biden is
convicted and sent to prison for weird
shoulder massages will he still be able
to vote that's what they're gonna debate
at the next CNN Town Hall you know I
have long defended Joe Biden on this
line of attack I think it is totally
disingenuous it is probably being
launched by the Bernie Sanders campaign
it is making a mountain out of a
molehill he's a weird guy who gives
weird shoulder massages and smells
women's hair I'm not saying that that is
normal behavior however why is he doing
it he's clearly doing it to ingratiate
himself he is a glad-handing walking
simple of a politician that is his whole
shtick he's doing all of it on camera
there has never been an allegation that
he's jumping around hotel rooms cheating
on his wife or anything like that
so I think it's a weak attack but I've
long said Joe Biden is a weak candidate
I think he's a total paper tiger he ran
in 88
lotty ran in 2008 he flopped the only
reason he got to be vice president is
because Barack Obama hated Hillary
Clinton so much I don't think he's going
anywhere if Joe Biden can't withstand
this flimsy attack by a former campaign
volunteer for Bernie Sanders which is
who that woman is Lucy Flores was a big
booster of Bernie Sanders and I believe
she remains so if you can't weather that
kind of an attack you ain't going
nowhere that is a that is nothing he
should have been able to brush that off
in two seconds so maybe he'll announce
on Thursday maybe he won't he's playing
Hamlet for now we have another candidate
entering the race now a guy named Seth
Moulton he is from the 6th congressional
district of Massachusetts he just
announced his campaign yesterday was
first called to service in my college
church by a minister who's the greatest
mentor I ever had they talked a lot
about the importance of service about
how it's not enough just to believe in
service you got to find a way to get
back yourself you couldn't help but sit
in this church and be hit by the names
on these walls and I had so much respect
for them that I wanted to do my part too
so I joined the Marines my parents
weren't exactly throughout
really scared for him even in a war I
disagreed with there's nothing I'm more
proud of than being a grunt being on the
ground serving with those Marines before
I knew it I was commanding a platoon in
the first company of Marines into
Baghdad his campaign manager his
pollster told him to quit and you don't
tell us that to quit
how many more Democrat presidential
announcement ads are we gonna have to
hear this ridiculous platitude you know
when he announced he was gonna run all
everybody told so-and-so to quit but you
don't tell so-and-so to quit so-and-so
doesn't quit he can't quit he doesn't
even know the word quit he's not a
quitter so and so's not a quitter it's
Eric's wall welds campaign ad all over
again also this guy Seth Moulton white
male Marine probably not exactly the
demographic that identity obsessed
Democrats are looking for in twenty
twenty twenty twenty twenty candidates
running Booker Buddha judge Castro John
Delaney Tulsi Gabbard Kirsten Gillibrand
Kamala Harris John Hickenlooper jay
Inslee Columbia char Wayne messin bado
O'Rourke Tim Ryan Bernie Sanders Eric
SWA well Elizabeth Warren marianne
williamson
she's a spiritual author and counselor
to Oprah Andrew yang now Seth Moulton
possibly Joe Biden in a couple days I
thought this might be a long drawn-out
thing looking at their performances on
CNN I'm wondering if this isn't gonna
thin out real quick these are weak
candidates they are not like the
Republican candidates in 2016 those
Republican candidates most of them were
extremely strong candidates Marco Rubio
Ted Cruz obviously these were Jeb Bush
actually was a was at least a serious
candidate Donald Trump turned out to be
one Rand Paul these were tough people
who did know what they think and were
able to put up a fight
lots of others as well these are not
these are for the most part pretty weak
candidates the fear here is if they all
stay in too long Bernie Sanders is going
to be able to come in win a plurality in
a number of states
walk his way to the nomination with
without actually winning too many votes
that's the fear he's running the
strongest right now including Joe Biden
and the only hope is the total weakness
of these candidates they're all trying
to be Bernie but you can't out Bernie
Bernie and if you don't really believe
it if you're not a true believer who
takes his shirt off in swills vodka and
sings this land is my land this land is
your land with Soviets in the 80s you
really can't pull off the commies shtick
we'll see how long this this lasts I
want to start taking bets on who's gonna
be out of this race before the first
debate we'll find out after a couple
more CNN Town Hall's speaking of town
halls come see me tonight at Cal State
LA we will be talking about the wall we
will be talking about immigration we'll
be talking about how this land is my
land go check it out otherwise I'll see
you tomorrow in the meantime I'm Michael
Knowles this is the Michael Nolt show
[Music]
the Michael Noel's show is produced by
Rebecca dabka wits and directed by Mike
joiner executive producer Jeremy boring
senior producer Jonathan hey our
supervising producer is Mathis Glover
and our technical producer is Austin
Stevens edited by Dani D'Amico Audio is
mixed by Dylan case hair and makeup is
by Jeshua Alvaro and our production
assistant is Nick Sheehan the Michael
Noel's show is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 20 19 today on the
Ben Shapiro show Democrats compete for
attention on CNN and the media downplay
Srilanka that's today on a bench Shapiro
show